hi my name is tangos Lynne chambers hi
YouTube my name is Tamara chambers and
this is Tamara jests uh I just went and
saw Logan lucky or as I refer to it on
Twitter as lucky Logan this is a film
that I heard very little about going
into it didn't know what the premise was
let's be honest like most films that I
see and I was really pleasantly
surprised when it was a heist movie
there was comedy the cast was stellar
and it had a really awesome
artsy feel to it that really made me
feel like I was watching more than just
a heist movie I don't know I've been
watching a lot of Edgar Wright films
recently there was kind of an artfulness
to it not in the same exact way that he
directs it was just really pretty and
and really well done who was the
director of this
oh it's Steven Soderbergh I actually
know who this is
he directed Ocean's eleven which I've
seen bits and pieces of I probably have
seen the whole thing I just don't really
remember it that well it came out a long
time ago 16 years it had an and an artsy
ER field than I would have expected if I
knew this was a heist film going in it
had more of an elevated feel in terms of
the presentation it was just really
pretty and really pleasing to watch the
cinematography blew me away
that's so funny they they actually
mention Ocean's eleven they call the
heist that these guys pull off ocean
7/11 because it's a redneck town and I
love no knowing that's that's such a
great not even Easter Egg but just such
a good call out to to his previous work
which interesting that he's just like
the king of the heist movies also
Channing Tatum and Adam driver were
incredible as brothers and you got the
the dynamic that's the one is the older
brother obviously one is the older
brother
Channing Tatum and then Adam driver is
kind of just following along he wants to
live up to like kind of what he expects
of him Adam driver is a war vet who lost
his arm and so he's got a prosthetic the
whole time which I'm always blown away
when
editing can just pull it off efforts not
effortlessly but seamlessly I guess it's
the word same in Mad Max with furiosa I
just think that's so impressive and I
just I'm so faithful that I don't have
the job of editing that together the
whole time he's saying that he's not
missing an arm he's just missing a hands
because he still has like his arm and
it's just it's really good he's got what
seems to be a good sense of humor about
it but I think that's just for the
audience to have I don't think he
actually as a character does more of it
doesn't register as it being a joke when
he brings that up the the Logan Brothers
and their sister who is what's her name
Riley Keough Keanu Riley something she
was stellar
they all are there the Logan family and
they are they have this curse and that's
where Logan lucky comes in and the film
really isn't that much about than being
lucky or unlucky it's really about them
pulling off this heist to steal money
from NASCAR America and then you see
kind of the relationships intertwined
within that and it's really just about
these humans
the heist didn't seem to have that much
kind of motivation they they aren't well
off with money channing tatum's
character doesn't have a job at the
moment he also was hurt his leg he's got
a limp and so he was let go from his job
which his boss Jim o'heir Jim o'heir
from Parks and Rec I love him he was in
it in a small part
David Denman from the office was in it
Seth MacFarlane was in it as 2007 team's
most unlikable character oh my god I
find it easy to not like Seth MacFarlane
I think he carries this confidence that
can easily go the wrong way can like rub
the wrong way I like it that's not where
I'm saying I think he's super talented I
like the work that he does but it was
believable for me to watch him be
unlikable and this is what I'm trying to
say and boy howdy was he unlikable y'all
the biggest
prize of this film for me was seeing
Daniel Craig in this film you guys have
to see him in this it's it is absolutely
mind-blowing I had no idea it was him I
was like I recognize you but I don't
think you're who I think I think you are
think I am think you are think and you
when I saw it was Daniel Craig I was
like oh obviously it's of course Daniel
Craig but also what the hell in my
opinion he stole every scene that he was
a part of
he was so enjoyable and I didn't like
him in some of the scenes I didn't like
the character you feel for all of these
characters I feel like except for Seth
MacFarlane's character no but if you
feel for all of these main characters
pulling off this heist even though
they're not perfect humans which is such
a great thing about films like this I
just love that I've said a lot and
Tamra's never seen that I don't like
unlikable characters as the lead as the
main character it just really pisses me
off even if they're good films but this
is there's there's some unlikable
qualities for all for all these guys
whether they're just a little awkward or
or like they're kind of you know what
criminals it's really exciting to to
still be able to root for them and still
want them to pull off this heist the
biggest kind of emotional connection in
the film was definitely Channing Tatum's
character and his daughter Channing
Tatum's character once upon a time was
married to Katie Holmes who I haven't
seen something in a long time and girl
looks great girl was great girl great
breaker age she did a really good job in
this part though it was very small they
have this sweet precious daughter
together and there is a moment I won't
reveal the moment there is a moment in
this film with dad and daughter that
really just gosh damn it it just touches
my little cold dead heart take me home
country roll 2
please where I belong West Virginia
Mountain Mama take me home country road
it's so cute you guys just see this film
if not for this wonderful
father-daughter relationship I think if
I could have wished for something else
in this it would have been to add a
little bit more comedy because I felt
really sad for the characters a lot of
the time and and nothing really majorly
sad happens it's just it's a it's a
really good portrayal of a real life
what's real life is sad I was trying to
decide if I should say or not but I said
it I said I also loved the trailers and
previews that you get before films like
this this wasn't distributed through a
giant company they're trying to do this
on their own I guess is what I just run
on my phone so at the end it said Amazon
Prime which is I guess I got like a
Netflix movie like the same kind of vein
so big company big big studios but not
you know Universal so it had that
independent feel to it like I said I
went into this without knowing anything
about it I had never seen any preview
for it ever anywhere so it's very it's
weird to see a movie like that now cuz
because films in theatres you you know
about you know you know you know you
know you know you know you know so the
trailers before our other independent
works and they are so cool I love seeing
them it was a lot longer you get to see
way more previews than you normally do
yeah I was already pumped before the
movie started just because I was like I
can't wait to see all of these films
also cannot wait to see I know this is
actually a big film but mother
exclamation point with Jennifer Lawrence
I am so pumped for that you have no idea
country road anyways thank you for
joining me so much of this independent
adventure okay so next week really
nothing is coming out fun views galore
can't wait but the week after that is it
which I am just dying to see I cannot
wait for that and then the week after
that is mother exclamation point so
cannot wait for those two weeks next
week we'll see what I scrape on by today
I almost saw nut job - just because
animated films usually do better for
this specific show Tamra just sucks so
glad I didn't subject myself to that let
me know what I can do to improve this
series I love doing cameras never seen
and I'm still figuring this one out you
know a good couple
six months later I really do enjoy and
appreciate constructive criticism I
would love for you to tweet it at me
Tamra L chambers at Twitter uh-huh and I
I really want to develop this into
something that can be lasting versus me
just yelling the same thing for ten
minutes let me know thank you so much
for watching and I'll see you all next
week
bye
[Music]